ALI AFSHAR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
Today we're going to be talking
about the Google Drive
SDK Early Access Program.
I'm joined today by Greg, and
my name is Ali, and we both
work on Google Drive Developer
Relations.
So thank you for joining
in today.
If you've attempted to come to
this video session in the
past, you know that we've
actually failed
to put it on twice.
So I'm figuring third
time lucky.
And thanks for your patience
and thanks
for coming here today.
I think this is evidence that
Google are capable of
recording a video and putting
it on the internet.
So yes, yay, us.
But anyway, thanks for coming.
So what is the Early
Access Program?
Well, we have a number of
features coming up with Google
Drive and we would like people
to use these in the real
world, real applications
to use them and give us
recommendations on how
they should improve.
We really take your feedback
seriously and we really need
to test this out in the real
world to see if the features
are what people need.
I don't mean to test it as in
quality-- we test all the
quality and make sure
everything works--
but we really want to know how
well this fits in with your
applications and whether it's
useful, how it could be more
useful, that kind of thing.
GREG KNOKE: So what can
developers expect to see in
the Early Access Program,
and what are the
requirements for them?
ALI AFSHAR: So we will
take developers--
all kinds of developers,
actually.
What they can expect is to be
part of the mailing list, have
access to all new features as
they come, so as they arrive,
we indicate this, we send an
email to the mailing list and
you'll know about it.
And then you can be whitelisted
to use those features.
So they're hidden to all
other developers.
They won't be able
to use them.
So that's what you'll see,
you'll see a regular stream of
new features added.
What do we expect?
Well, we kind of expect
you to use them.
We hope that you will, and
that's the whole point of it.
So there's no point in being on
the program if you're not
going to use the features
or you're not
going to give us feedback.
As I said, we're really
desperate to
get this from you.
So they'll be part of a list and
hopefully give us feedback
after trying the features.
GREG KNOKE: So what feature
should developers be most
excited about?
What will they be able to
implement now that they
wouldn't have been able to
previously with their apps?
ALI AFSHAR: So that's the other
side of it, and I'm glad
you raise that.
This also gives your application
a jump on their
competition, really.
So you get these features early
if you're [INAUDIBLE]
with Google Drive.
You'll be ready to launch this
feature to production when the
feature itself launches
on Google Drive.
So that gives you, I don't know,
a few month head start
over all the other
competitions.
So that's the other benefit.
What are the features we've
got at the moment?
Well the first one is our
real-time collaborative API.
We've spoken about
that in the past.
It's a really cool thing, it
allows multiple locked-in
sessions to collaborate in
the same way that you can
collaborate over Google Docs
when you get the little cursor
that moves around the screen
telling you that Greg is also
editing this document.
That framework is available as
a service for you to use on
your own files.
All part of our commitment to
make your applications as good
and as complete and as
feature-rich as the Google
Docs applications.
So that's the first one.
The second one we've got going
at the moment is push
notifications, so when a file
changes in Google Drive we
will send your application a
notification of the change and
then you can look up to see
what the changes happen.
That's really, really important
for certain kinds of
applications that are either
collaborative--
you want to see if someone
else has edited it--
or, for example, a synchronizing
or backup
application.
You only want to perform
the backup when
something has changed.
You don't want to keep
polling to see if the
change has taken place.
So you use push notifications.
So we have the real-time
API, we have the push
notifications.
And quite excitingly, the
features we're launching in
the next few weeks are all
based around using Google
Drive as a collaborative--
as an application platform
for your files.
So what do I mean by that?
We've added a way recently
to hide certain
files from the user.
Your application will get a
folder of its own that is
something like a configuration
folder.
The user owns it, so they can
delete it, but they can't look
at it and modify it.
So that's perfect for putting
your configuration files or
any other files that are
associated with your
application that you don't
want user to edit--
backups of your applications
data from a mobile app would
be perfect use case for this.
That's part of it.
The other side of the apps
platform that we're building
is that you will have
the ability to
add data onto files.
So you can decide, I
want to tag this
file with my own data.
And that feature will be coming
soon and added to the
Early Access Program.
So rather than before when we
were going through individual
features and seeing who would
like to try this out, who
should we try this out, we're
opening this up to you.
You can innovate how you like.
We might not anticipate that you
would be interested in a
certain feature, so that's why
we're bringing them all
together and we're letting
you go for that.
So push notifications, real-time
collaboration,
application data, and meta data
associated with files.
Those are the features
we've got at the
moment, more to come.
If you want to apply, you
need to go to our site--
developers.googl
e.com/drive/earlyaccess.
One word, we'll publish
the link.
There, you can fill
out a form.
Thank you for all your
applications.
As I said, we actually launched
this a few weeks ago
and we've only got round
to doing the video now.
Thank you for your
applications--
we've had hundreds.
So going through them, we have
quite strict criteria on the
kind of application that we
think would be suitable.
So we're going through them and
we should have a response
for everyone by the
end of the week.
So thank you very much.
Those of you who haven't
applied, now is a really good
time to do it because we've all
got our reviewing hats on
so that will get done soon.
So firstly, thank you.
And secondly, we'll get back
to you soon, and thanks for
your patience.
Right.
Any questions, Greg?
Anything to add?
GREG KNOKE: Sounds like
you covered it all.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, brilliant,
right.
Thank you all for coming.
Again, sorry about the previous
videos that failed.
And we'll see you soon on
Google Developers Live.
Thank you.
GREG KNOKE: Thank you.